salam alikum warahmatu labor okay so how
are you guys doing a quick one actually
this is not gonna be a quick one because
I'm gonna do quite a review before I do
so her job 10 and you get 10% off these
premium black seed products another
thing I wanted to say was in addition to
this the humbler will let you guys have
been able to raise money fifty five
thousand pounds for a life village which
will have amazing economic benefits for
this village which can now I mean you
don't understand how amazing this is
because people in garden out in tamale
they'll be able to to educate themselves
and to do all these things you can get a
school built with that money we're gonna
have a mechanical borehole bore holes
and so on all of that installed in the
area what I wanted to speak to you guys
about today was my five years
is half a decade now and the debates
i've done i've done many informal
debates but i've done six six formal
ones major formal ones yeah
obviously the main one that i'd done
with the most views and the most
controversy was the one with david wood
that's one debate and done a debate with
with i'm not knowing order here but I've
done the bit with large goal one
liberalism
I don't debate with the Edward tabash on
atheism I've done a debate with I've
done a Shiite abate I forget the guys
name actually but he was one of the cie
people mullah so I've done two of those
actually which I would consider two
formal debates with this year and
obviously the one with cosmic skeptic as
well so these are six debates in Oxford
University hosted by the forum Oxford
University for so these are the six
major debates had done in the five years
other than that you know obviously I've
done a lot of informal stuff and what I
wanted to put to you is that there's a
recurring trend as to what happens
usually after these debates these
debates if you add them together we're
talking about tens of millions of views
yeah not just on my channel but on
whoever's channel that they went on and
they were translated into many languages
many of them have been translated into
many languages so we're talking about
audiences from across the world yeah
and my own personal experience with them
is that a lot of people actually convert
to Islam from them and that's not just
me saying this I can provide evidences
if one want me to look into my inboxes
and oh I've become Muslim after watching
the David would debate cetera that has
happened okay a lot of people have in
the Muslim community obviously have with
the specialty David would debate and
have felt okay they had some doubts
which were then dismissed and and so on
these are some of the positives but in
terms of from the other side what are
some of the recurring themes that we
find from the other side some of the
recurring themes relate to my demeanor
how I actually interrogate my opponent
how I actually deal with my opponent now
most people will not deal with my
arguments because if you think about all
of the arguments I've ever put forward
in public debates yeah
when there's a controversial backlash
it's not usually on what I am putting
forward in terms of content like for
example with the David Wood debate I
made three arguments one from scripture
one from rationality and one from
history that the Trinity was a
historical development that it wasn't
something which was there from the very
beginning and over 300 years it was
developed that was my argument and that
it rationally it doesn't make sense that
was another part of the Allium
scripturally it's not something which is
naturally inferred from the plain
reading of the text that's something
else I said and these three arguments
are interlinked where is the post debate
backlash on the arguments that I made
there isn't really much I'll be honest
with you there isn't much there's
usually an attack on how I dealt with
David Wood oh I'm very or he's very
obnoxious he's very bad man he's very
okay okay no problem I haven't got a
problem being labeled a bad man and a
hypocrite and dishonest and obnoxious
and let me just put that out there for
you guys I'm very happy that you guys
had to do that because at the end of the
day that's not that's not an argument
against my argument that's not a
counter-argument same thing now with
tabash and large school by the way I
have a very cordial relationship
especially Edward Tabish I still speak
to him on emails there wasn't really
much of an issue and he did attempt in
his debate to deal with my arguments he
did attempt to deal with the actual
argument
I usually put for Jace's is a
contingency argument I've written a book
about it and you know I feel confident
about that argument I felt a strong
argument so I put the argument forward
and that wasn't refuted sorry that was
attempted ly refuted but I don't think
it was successfully reviewed so with
with law school the liberalism thing was
a back and forth and actually if you
think about that debate with law school
is on liberalism there was actually
agreement on that debate that liberalism
is based on axiomatic presuppositions
therefore it can't be users and you know
a it cannot be used as a kind of
barometer for all kinds of morality and
so on and so forth yeah my two other
debates now with the Shia have a
straightforward argument that the two
debates this year was the same argument
that all of the Isola Deen the
foundations of the religion are found in
the Quran like for example we have
hadith with debris the hadith of Jubran
you know that we believe and when I when
the professor Sam was also a man a man
and took men below me like a kitty who
could to be hero slowly he were warmly I
record the hidey-ho shall be that you
believe in Allah and the messengers and
and you know the books and the angels
and these are the we call the pillars of
Eman of Islam my argument was ok we have
the all of the pillars of Islam of Eman
in the Quran but we don't have a Mammon
or on any explicitly stated anymore you
know so you have to use try and infer it
or try and squeeze it in try and do an I
see Jesus that was the argument
so what's that argument refuted no it
wasn't and it continues to be made and
that argument was made twice and you
know if I ever see sei again and I
debated them with about this I probably
make the same argument because why
should I fix something which is not
broken
I might phrase it differently or
something but I think it's a very strong
argument my debate was was spit was
skeptic was the same thing I put forth a
contingency argument in terms of the
backlash I got your dishonest man you're
a bad man you're you you stop the
comments you know you misrepresented me
you miss quoted me
ok let's grant for a sake of argument
that I did all of those things okay I'm
a bad man I'm dishonest I'm a hypocrite
I'm a thug I'm violent I'm
all of those bad things which by the way
on your morality cannot be described as
bad it's just all of those
characteristics from your perspective
you can't be bad because on what on what
basis is it bad but all of those things
right I'm a thug I'm all of those things
I'm yeah okay but what happened to my
contingency argument what happened to my
argument for Islam being the truth what
happened to the arguments that I put
forward for you because at the end of
the day I didn't get any from from all
of the reactions I've gotten I didn't
get one things at our his argument was
wrong even when you when when he tried
to and he's supposed to be commentary
tried to refute me on points of
difference on the logical forms of the
organs of P if P in tells Q and P is
true then Q must be true and I said no
so yeah obviously it's if that form is
correct yeah and he said you're
inconsistent okay even if I wasn't
consistent there for the sake of volume
unless I was inconsistent no problem how
does that disturb my contingency
argument because we've misunderstood
each other on that point that was the
only substance based thing that you said
in your in your post debate discussion
how does that disturb my my main
contention just to remind everyone of
what the contingency argument is because
I think it's very important yeah is that
they can't be a world of just possible
existences and possible existence is not
just one thing possible existence is
just not just defined as something that
can be any other way it's also something
which is dependent I reliant on
something else in order to exist
so these two definitions must be put
together in order for you to understand
what monkey know will do it or what
possible existence is it's not just
something which could have been any
other way
but it's something which is dependent so
let me put this straightforwardly for
for anyone to understand for any atheist
so maybe because I think what's been
lost in translation here is the actual
argument too much is being said oh you
said she said he said you're a bad man
dishonest you know whatever okay I'm a
bad man pretend I'm a bad man I'm a bad
man I for the sake of argument I agree I
know even for the sake of argument I
don't consider myself a good man yeah I
don't
I actually don't I don't have a high
regard for I don't think I'm not
a bastion of impeccable virtue and
character I'm not saying that this is
the representation an archetype no we we
say that that's prophet muhammad's
answer them anyway so I don't I don't
have any moral obligation to be a good
man to anyone yeah but my arguments are
my arguments so what is the argument the
argument is that dependent things cannot
depend upon other dependent things ad
infinitum that's the argument because if
you have dependent things dependent upon
dependent things ad infinitum okay then
you have in this analogy like dominoes
falling upon each other so let me give
you another analogy right if you go to
the sea if you go to the sea you and I
will be justified in believing that the
sea has a sea floor yeah we will both be
justified in believing that the sea has
a sea floor but why would we be
justified I believe in that having not
seen the sea floor itself we infer that
from the fact that our mind yes almost
intuitively realizes that they can't be
just water balancing upon itself add
infinite infinitely there must be some
kind of foundation here right so we say
the same thing applies with existence in
the context of existence in the context
of existence everything that exists that
we can see and feel and have experience
with is dependent so this this t-shirt
is dependent is a this camera that this
phone is dependent on some kind of
charge and so on and so forth
this is very important the argument here
is there cannot be just a world of
dependent things without there being one
independent that holds all the dependent
things up and we call this okay um in in
Quranic terminology all the maintainer
the one who rises everything up it's
also referred to as a summit these are
all Quranic technologies that's our
basic definition of what this is
basically it so the argument is in order
for you to refute my position you have
to show how it's possible for there to
be a world of only dependent things with
no independent thing at all okay because
the moment you say this is the
independent thing then you've lost your
atheism you're no longer an atheist
you've become at least at
you've entered in - I'm not saying this
is all what God is by the way yeah I'm
not saying how God is only the
independent one no we have so many
things so many attributes of God which
can be understood it's so facto through
Quranic understanding but that's aside
the point so the argument has not been
refuted
I'm afraid the argument has not been
referred there has been not in fact what
makes me really upset with my final
debate is that there has not been even
an effort to refute the argument there's
been more of an effort to refute me
oh you're dishonest man is a
misrepresentation you know you're you're
bad man ok all of those things are fine
I know you're gonna say that yeah you
can call me whatever you want but my
argument is robust and you know what
it's not my argument the reason why I so
robust is because it's been persistent
throughout the ages this argument is one
that's been made throughout the
Hellenistic period throughout the
medieval period into the Enlightenment
period and currently made for a you know
in in popular academics so something and
Eason it's an Eastern academic tradition
and Western academic Trish this is
something which is effectively
irrefutable so the argument has not been
refuted atheism hasn't got a leg to
stand on
yeah you misrepresented me you're a bad
man you block in the comments hold
comments for review ok all those things
I agree I do I do all comers review
because you know why because when I see
a lot of people coming in and start
saying your prophet is a P word you
listen that and I can't delete all of
that I'm on the go and this and that so
what I say what I'm gonna hold it for
review I've got some people managing my
Adnan say look if the comments are
conducive put them through if they don't
conducive then you know I do what you
want with them I will leave them or
delete them so yeah we don't need to we
have no obligation to allow you to
insult us I'm sorry and if you think we
do have silence you have your religion I
have mine you have your way I have my
way but so just to kind of finalize this
year the six major debates that I've
done and the three major books I've
written I'm sorry to say all of them
have the main arguments I've made
throughout my works either informal
debates or my books have not been
reviewed and it's not because our very
clever and it's not because I'm clever
I'm just standing on the on the
shoulders of giants
I'm taking examples
arguments which have been made
historically and continue to be made now
formally for millennia these arguments
been made for thousands of years so what
I'm doing is presenting them to you I
don't expect you to be able to deal with
them because no one has been able to
deal them before you do you get it but
at least have the integrity and decency
to try and challenge it try and
challenge the arguments okay you know
what I might not agree with Muhammad
hijab he's a bad man bla bla bla
however his arguments deal with the
arguments stop dealing with me you okay
I'm a bad man you won I'm a bad man
I you know I put my hands up I'm a very
bad man I don't even want you to think
of me as a good man you know why as the
Arabic poet said clearly Leahey a smell
almost nafferton totally Antilla
that even about a lot I say bad things
you'll be able to see this every about
Allah so about God himself obviously
you're an atheist here watching this
stuff no probably don't believe in God
but for us God is the be-all and end-all
yeah for us
Godsey is the axiom axiom all the the if
you like the light that makes everything
else possible to see so if you're gonna
say if you're gonna be like God then by
virtue of that facts you're gonna be
lying human beings who cool - his way
yeah or promote God in any way so it
makes sense right no problem
deal so this is my message I've got
publish works I've got six debates if
someone is serious about wanting to
refute me yeah
it's been washed tens of millions of
times all of those debates take our tens
of millions yeah if someone is serious
about wanting to refute me then be very
serious by making an academic response
to the main argument and let me be very
specific here if I made mistakes in my
presentation that does not affect but be
very very careful what I'm saying if I
make mistakes in my presentation which
does not affect the veracity and
robustness of my main argument you
reviewing those mistakes is not
tantamount to you refuting my argument
that's just you refuting me my
fallibilities
you're just outlining my fallibilities
so this is my message to everybody look
the arguments are there and you know
what last thing I want to put this to
you to everybody here so the Atheist
communicate to those who consider
themselves liberals to those systems of
Shia to all of those who have ever
debated here's what I'll say to you guys
I want you to remember this yeah I know
you're waiting for me to engage here but
that's what screw just you know yes yes
what I want to say to you is that when
you refute in me refute me on the basis
of disproving my main argument such that
your refutation I'm telling you how to
review your refutation will nullify the
argument so yeah for example if I say
for 300 years or for about 300 years or
for X amount of years X hasn't happened
or let's say let's use a rule example or
let's say the Trini is it's irrational i
zaboor it's not something you can
rationalize free and one one and free
that's my argument so you have to show
me a way where it is rationalizing for
david wouldn't do that his followers
didn't do that there has been things
that written on it you know in
academically but it's not respected
outside of Christian echo chambers so
once again
atheism when I say is good is how do we
how do we gain how do we gain you say
okay what are the options I've worked in
from nothing or the universe was always
here but why is it dependent on so we go
back to a contingency standpoint you
have to give us some kind of
rationalizing
if you don't want to then you have to
defeat what we're saying you don't say
okay I'm an agnostic
no prob we can be like Gnostic we have
to defeat what we're saying why is it
that the contingency argument is for
example there's other arguments but I'm
just giving you this one why is it wrong
why is it wrong why doesn't it work what
do you see the point so instead okay the
CIA polemic when I say okay well there's
nothing in the Quran about the Imams
explicitly but there is about this is
you have to show actually there is
something in the Quran that will just
prove me straight away actually look at
this verse it says you know X
or your criteria is wrong and this is
why your criteria so you have to be
robust yeah so you know not sure what I
want to bring to the people is I know it
boils the blood of the people who cannot
refute robust arguments to see me do I
do I know it does
and you know what if I was on the other
side I probably have boiled blood as
well and I'd be eating myself up and
speaking about this man's debates one
year two years three years five years
after he died uh you know and you know
what I'm very happy that you do that
because it shows me is successful
because if my debates were not
successful you wouldn't even talk about
it but here's my challenge to all of
those people that are against what I
believe in
you have to disprove my main arguments
and they're on the public record and
they're also on written form so it
shouldn't be that difficult and that's
how you're gonna show me that I'm not
only that I'm wrong because I know I'm
wrong yeah I'm very bad than wrong but
what I believe in is wrong and there's a
big difference between the two
dishonest man misrepresent this and that
yeah no problem but is what I believe in
wrong you're gonna have to show me the
evidence for that was Salam alaikum
warahmatullahi over again